the magazine was one thing but this
you're good the new room is fun to be
the new bride rearranging the bachelors
apartment putting flowers out it's just
not nice to think you might find a
corpse in the freezer you know look
weird with lot of scandals you never
quite know when you're in the middle of
the rainstorm and went to the first
drops and when you reach the end of it
we wanted to try and give that slightly
sickening sense of without the worst
moment of it and also the worst thing
that we're going to hear happened a
problem they have someone else for later
in the week who could probably kill us
who a victim she comes out in the NDA's
Domino there's concentric circles of
levels of knowledge you can be pretty
compelling when you've aside yourself
you did or didn't know something this
supposed victim could meet up with her a
little talk you know find out what she
wants
apologize one of you both of you please
it's one of those moments where your
sense of yourself and your own moral
parameters are tested a bit and what's
painful for them boat is that they know
that they've been asked to go and do
that particular job because they are
women why she was able to do something
which other people might find undoable
is because she's already feels like
they've had all those arguments
we're in the car now let's just go and
do it good thing is you're gonna have a
lot of people on your side but the other
people normal people they will doubt in
your life is gonna get ripped apart from
tomorrow that's all you'll ever be we're
just thinking about people's personal
responsibilities to take on political
cultural change which is going to be
damaging to them and the people who
choose to do that are very brave but it
was your best friend or your mother or
sister could you hand on heart tell them
to do it it's an interesting dilemma
[Music]
you